welcome back now LA's homeless can keep
clean with their very own Street washing
machine
yeah if you're an LA squader your tent
may have electricity and water
some of LA's homeless are getting so
bold they're now siphoning water and
power from the city streets and hooking
up appliances the city's got more
illegal hookups than R Kelly
have their own washing machine
as well put that street poop to good use
am I right
business owners and other locals are
pretty Fed Up they've been snapping pics
and videos of the insanity sharing it
online they've even considered in the
encampments front yards just to see how
they like it
I made that part up
so people are stealing City Water and
Power as they please soon there will be
brownouts in the city and on the
sidewalk
a lot of poop humor today and it's not
just one neighborhood there's
encampments all over the city with
full-size tents and cordon off streets
it's like a street fair except the theme
is hepatitis and Night Fights
there's an idea so with 70 000 people on
the street it makes sense homelessness
is the dominant issue in LA's upcoming
mayoral election both candidates Rick
Caruso and Karen bass say they'll make
it easier to build new affordable
housing and expand the city's shelter
system the outgoing mayor Eric Garcetti
says he did that too and it only
expanded the problem onto sidewalks and
public parks fact is when you make it
easier to be homeless you just attract
more homeless like cat did when she was
single that's true
but at least their clothes will smell
better and hey everyone should wash
their rug once in a while which is what
I tell Waters about is toupee
clay can get back to its Glory Days when
the only thing that stank was the new De
Niro movie
[Laughter]
you suck Peter
we've had these Solutions yeah this is
not like I don't I I know the homeless
in this in New York they are not looking
for affordable housing yeah they're not
like do you know this is this three
thousand dollar a month uh uh
apartment's too much for me I'm looking
for something in the 2500 range no they
if they have 2 500 that's going into
their arm that's right that's right and
look this is California so let's
remember the homeless are not going to
get in trouble setting up these tent
cities they might get in trouble if
those washing machines are not high
energy efficient washing machines right
that's what's going to get them in
trouble yeah and that's the you know
that's the Absurd nature of what they're
doing I mean these are people whose
lives are suffering and in the name of
sort of freedom and tolerance uh they're
taking over these areas it's affecting
the quality of life I think the
interesting thing though is Greg that so
much of this is now happening in these
liberal enclaves in these cities places
like Los Angeles if this was a red
neighborhood where this was taking place
the city of Los Angeles wouldn't care
they're going to be getting phone calls
now from very powerful donors who are
saying I'm tired of this you need to do
something about it yeah you know uh cat
you just recently got your own washer
and dryer no yeah I mean you married
yeah it was part of the uh what do you
call it I've actually known that was
part of the Dowry I think you I think
you gotta go I've actually never bought
a piece of furniture in my entirely I'm
turning 34 on Saturday I've never bought
Furniture I've only inherited it so good
for you yeah I think so I think that uh
but yeah it's it's like the streets set
up over there is a lot nicer than like
the a lot of the apartments that do cost
thousands of dollars in New York yeah
like maybe you're living on on the
street but how many people can say they
have on-site laundry yeah exactly
nobody and it's you know what they call
what they call it in real estate inside
outside living right where you got like
open Concepts you can walk I can sit on
the couch and watch lights yeah watch TV
but there's no wall here that's inside
outside living everybody wants that now
this opportunity yeah there's
opportunity I mean maybe they can open
up a homeless dry cleaning and
alterations yeah
me but uh my shirt's missing a sleeve
now there's blood and piss on it
I'm killing my Jack
ET he needed it
yeah you know what but there's an idea
oh we finally evolving into these
Villages that we saw in science fiction
movies where they do actually they'll
have their laundromat they might have
these little restaurants it could be oh
this could be a whole new thing okay
Gutfeld you dear sweet boy
um in those Sci-Fi movies you forget the
other part the rich then ate them y'all
they let them have their own little
village and they rounded them up and
then these morlocks showed up and they
were on the plate for the elitist but
California is
dying I mean and I grew up there and
when you look at when you talk to
politicians they're like mission
accomplished like look at that they have
tents they have washing machines they
have quality of life yeah they just
don't care about the people who are
paying rent inside the houses and guess
what's going to happen to their rent
it's going to go up guess what's going
to happen to their electric bills who do
you think is going to pay for those
outdoor washing machines which is I
guess cool I've never done a load of
laundry in my life and I'm proud of that
just like you haven't bought Furniture
really yeah that is impressive a lot of
my dating in college was based on
folding and separating
I get it and you're not talking about
the clothes I am talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
what does that mean
no no no no you wanna you wanna clap why
does that mean
you have no idea
I hope they put washing machines in
front of your house
clean up your ass
that's true though I don't know what I'm
thinking right now I think it kind of
makes sense yeah
the delivery though was spot on
everybody went yeah that's
that's like it's supposed to be funny
it's not
[Laughter]
all right
well we solved nothing in this segment
and that means we're doing a good job
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else